and no when welcome to this video yeah I
kind of knew it right I saw him on the
list and I got all you got so what am i
doing against against his 90 of 31 see
we'll see how he plays this I have not
yet tried this against him so i'm unsure
Bishop g5 this is choice a I never again
again I don't try this against him let's
see they don't know don't know this line
all that way it's night before i move
here what's the deal with this what is
he doing here I don't quite understand
but take here 93 is this some trickery
don't quite see it 96 I mind some kind
of pin down this one okay
hmm ok I'll take him it doesn't do
anything can just take 97 this is a
simple solution he has Roxy one maybe no
one doesn't do it so just cancel then my
the problem here could be that pinning
is getting in some c5 and I cannot move
my DNB porn so I try to try to do this
now get my development up to speed yes
so do I go a 6b five in this position it
is possible a little bit unsure here but
ok as usual he just wants to trade
everything ok I can go Queen to c7 I
don't know if it's good though
as I said I think I still prefer it to
other things other setups ok be five we
should be seven hero goes with some a
form I guess
it should be seven there might be some
syntactic but i don't i don't think
there should be six a half knight c6 i
think ok so here I can go knight c6 as
well 25 though I have to be careful yes
it's just as usual not doing anything
and just trades down the house and then
you're sitting down I'd have no time I
did a blonde at the airport Jack I did
blunder the airport cool stuff as it
happens you kind of place yourself to
sleep ok
so I think objectively speaking out
still should not lose this I'm fairly
active he wants to play rooks cover the
rooks III which indeed is some step
forward step forward for him now
check okay nairobi i am rook c8 it
wasn't it wasn't exactly exactly tough
defense yeah yeah it's it it just lacks
the men's eyes I kind of I kind of fall
asleep oh and this in those games you
know just be sure to five or something
it's just absolutely nothing mmm what I
should do is actually um try to play for
an advantage she have it I didn't quite
didn't quite manage maybe it's it's a
bit too much to ask ask for advantage
but I mean here only black can be better
engine gives you five it's a move that I
considered of course but I didn't want
to open up this diagonal maybe this
isn't a big deal and this is indeed
quite comfortable I mean he has a bad
bone structure so I shouldn't be worse
here yeah this is all kind of okay with
you know I spent too much time on that
and then I get into some pressure he
actually could have won probably with
this according to the computer which is
pretty difficult to see my back rank and
95 is also strong yeah
it's really stranger but because I just
don't pay any attention you know check I
always think okay this is [ __ ] he
has nothing and this is this again is
also totally raw i justjust don't pay
attention this is the thing because I'm
so annoyed by him and this makes the
results even worse I don't have to do
something here against him I really hate
to do some of those games anyway thanks
for watching